hello and welcome we're glad you joined
us for this live webinar why aren't you
singing under the microscope how new
like a stereo microscopes can drive new
discoveries in your lab presented by dr.
Heinrich burgers I'm Suzy Valdez abroad
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and sponsored by Leica
Microsystems a world leader in providing
innovative microscopy camera and
software solutions for imaging and
analysis of micro macro and nano
structures before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this presentation
is interactive we want to hear from you
so questions and comments can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of this presentation also
you're viewing this presentation in a
stride window to enlarge that window
click on the icon in the lower right
hand corner of your slide window if you
cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and does offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
for obtaining your credits without
further ado I'd now like to present our
speaker today dr. Heinrich burgers dr.
burgers is a product manager at the
stereo and digital microscopy division
of life Microsystems based in here Berg
Switzerland he studied biology at the
University of Regensburg and Munich in
Germany after receiving his PhD from the
University of Heidelberg in Germany in
2009 he worked in the field of image
analysis and fluorescent slide scanning
before joining Leica Microsystems as a
sales rep in 2011
in 2014 he took on the role of product
manager in her Berg and is now taking
care of the fluorescence stereo
microscope line
dr. burgers will now begin his
presentation welcome sir hello and thank
you for joining this webinar where I
want to talk a little bit about what we
can see in the microscope and how this
can help us to make better decision in
this research when I'm talking about
decision-making in research I'm not
talking about the long thinking process
I'm talking about how to make a decision
which fly to use which one is the right
one the left one the right one is my
fish at the right stage all these
decisions you'll make all day in our
brain nearly intuitively and these
decisions are based on what we see under
the microscope under the stereo
microscope mostly and we may need to
make sure that we all see the same
details to have the same understanding
so in our laboratory we have to teach
and we have to make sure that everyone
sees there were the same thing and makes
the same decision this has a big
advantage because if we all make the
same decision if you all take about the
same thing then we improve the
probability level of our experiments and
this means we need maybe less
repetitions and we have maybe better
outcome and if you see more things and I
want to talk about innovation where you
can see maybe more things in a bigger
context even higher resolution at a
lower magnification then you may have an
advantage an advantage over other
microscope users which don't see the
same level of detail you do when we talk
about the work steps and the laboratory
were using a stereomicroscope
then I want to put this into three or
four portions
that's phenotyping clicking injecting
and maybe we can separate these a little
bit more because the one part is the
viewing part and the other part is the
manipulation part under the microscope
and with a better image you have
increased confidence and you can decide
can I continue with that sample is it
the right thing I'm doing where am i
setting my injection am i preparing the
right thing then once you have injected
maybe RNA DNA and you want to go and see
whether the fluorescence of your
proteins is stressed correctly and then
you need to decide do I want to
propagate that further or do I want to
move on to fluorescence imaging and in
the end you want to make some imaging
some measuring and you want to describe
what's happening in detail and over time
then there are a lot of other things
happening in the laboratory where the
microscope is most likely not involved
like she is prancing like biochemistry
and all these things still together then
form an image and hopefully the image
which you put in your publication is
made with like an instrument so let's
start with C elegans to see what we can
do for you with our new product and
quickly as an introduction what are you
challenges well the worms are moving
they're sometimes more than one
fluorescent signal for animal and what
you want to study in detail is you want
to stage the warm you want to pick what
is the one where you can see the gonads
you want to go for phenotyping so you
may want to see the weaver and you can
provide different solutions for you for
this and yes you need a base for good
contrast sometimes you also need a
yellowish light hello Jen like to get a
better contrast you want a low order
fluorescence for flu screenings lower
the fluorescence from the microscope and
from the base you maybe want to inject
something then I will
top quickly about inverted microscopes
and in the end you most likely go to a
upright confocal yeah we have a new
stereo microscope ds9
and here you can see the s9 I was the
integrated camera and talking about the
microscope what is important for you
then I found out that most C elegans
users need a magnification that goes
beyond 50 times and here we can offer 50
times magnification and you need a large
depth of field because not all worms are
on the same focus plane and not all
petri dishes are filled equally high
with agar and this can improve your
screening and sorting process you also
want the larger zoom range and the nine
stands for nine to one so you can go
from six 0.61 magnification to 55 times
and this means you can have the entire
plate in overview and then you can zoom
in onto the wall that you are interested
in and looking at the oculus it's pretty
important to have a good viewing angles
so that you can look inside and that you
have the right position and I will talk
a little bit about optics in a later
slide looking at the working distance I
think that's pretty important for to
software for C elegans because well you
have to manipulate your samples you have
these other dishes and you want to open
and close the lid here the space should
be sufficient then you want to work with
needles with forceps
maybe with brushes to take out a single
warm and put it somewhere and when
you're working with students then you
will find very often that the lenses are
dirty because if you go too close to the
warm because you need a lot lower
working distance then everything gets
dirty and because someone touches it and
the new s9 is delivered from the factory
with a protection glass in front of the
optics so you simply unscrew it you wash
it and you clean again
if you talk about the transmitted light
base then it should be big enough to
hold your petri dishes maybe more than
one and you want to inuvik petri dish
around without hanging and at some
borders which is very inconvenient
because it's the warm of interest is at
the corner you don't want to get stuck
somewhere and if you want to work
conveniently it's very important that
you have a good contest that easy to
adjust and easy to adjust mean for me
that you just contest once to what you
want and then you can stay at that
contrast this means if you zoom in and
out the contrast does not change too
much and you can always see the detail
level of detail you expect and this can
maybe look like this so there's only one
knob on the side to adjust contrast and
with a half turn you can go from bright
field to dark field and these are some
examples of what you may see and want to
see if you're warm another thing here
just consider is if you want to inject
warms then you need to prepare the warms
and you need to prepare the onesie you
can see an older lighter stereo and the
new inverter microscope on the left then
you need to pick the warm and you need
to transfer them somewhere on other pads
and these other pets should be sticky so
that the warm can't tolerate because you
want to inject maybe some RNA into the
gonads so you go to an inverted
microscope and this can be a relatively
easy to say manual microscope but it
should offer you some techniques for em
some techniques for contrasting and you
want to see the warm also 3d like on the
compound microscope here on that inverts
microscope and this means you need maybe
an integrated modulation contrast from
Leica because this differential
interference contrast you need polarized
light and if you're working on plastic
slides the polarization does not help
you
and then the DC image is bad you also
need a micro manipulator and an injector
and an anti vibration table yeah and
then if your warm is expressing the
fusion protein most likely this GFP you
want to screen it and you need to go to
relatively high magnification because
you want to see is the expression a is
the expression specific on specific and
this gives you the possibility to decide
should I go on with that sample or not
and maybe you're warm is expressing more
than one person's protein then you need
to have the possibility to make an
easier to change and making a filter
change for me or for like a means you
maybe don't need to take your hands off
the sampler you can maybe use a foot
switch and use a motorized filter to
switch from one filter to another if you
want to zoom or to focus you maybe want
to manual instrument because you feel
where I'm convenient with these manual
controls and if you prefer to switch
your filters by hand well that also
works with a motorized so jewelry water
because you just give the filter a
little push and that's why we invented
this new like guide which you can see
here this M 205 FCA and it has an
extremely large zoom range of twenty
point five to one and this means you can
go from low magnification to high
magnification if you have such a big
microscope you maybe want to single it
about Al Ghanim II and you can see here
they are good tilting tube on top which
allows you to adjust for taller users
and users which are maybe not so tall
and always it in a very convenient
position and the laboratory where you
want to screen and for essence if you
are looking at your worms and
fluorescence and you want to just pick
one then you maybe see the fluorescence
of the one here on the left side you
will see the order for essence from the
log R and the bacteria you see the where
the worms have been crouching in the
bacteria and now you find the right warm
and picking that warm is maybe not a
good idea without adding transmitted
light and the transmitted light base for
screening see elegance should be
possible to dim so low that you can
combine the fluorescence with the
transmitted light in a good contrast
because you can see here this form is
not alone and there are at least two
other ones pretty close which you could
pick by accident which are not
expressing the fluorescent protein and
this means you might spoil your culture
well now you have the right woman now
you go to imaging and yes you can do
imaging with fluorescent stereo
microscope here on use the left you see
the n2 or 5f a but more likely you will
go to an upright confocal microscope
because you don't want to look through
the auger you want to look from top
talking about the next model organism
about flies then we have some different
requirements I've seen in many
laboratories you use very different
microscopes so we use clean up stereos
like the s9 we use MGA stereo modular
ones the CMOS like the m60 ma t and i
want to talk a little about when to use
which one then you maybe want to prepare
something from a fly because if you are
interested in the fly brain and you
don't want to image the kit in which has
a lot of other fluorescence then you
need a high magnification stereo that
allows you to do this and then I want to
talk about coding why because you need
maybe reliable measurements and then we
have all these implications which mean
what does the microscope need to offer
to you a large field of view because you
want to get an overview over the Flies
on the fly pad you want to see enough
detail to discriminate between new
mutations others female male so you can
decide which flies to use you may want
to look at bristles and measure the
length or you want to look at ring size
if your population genetics and this
means you may
use different microscopes for all these
so looking here at the work steps in the
laboratory this looks pretty similar to
the C elegans we have still the
phenotyping picking and preparation you
always have to decide can I continue as
that sample is this the right fly and
then here in addition you need to
precise preparation for imaging
then you need to screening yes you want
to see is the first protein expressed
but you also maybe want to position your
sample before you go to control clear
the advantages position so that you get
good viewing angle on the confocal
something which is maybe later not so
easy to correct for and if you can do
this is a higher precision then you have
a higher reproducibility and then you
have an advantage because you need less
repetitions it work is more fun and in
the end yes we want you to publish so
what is important for Zola and here we
need multiple incident lighting
contrasting methods you need a
magnification that goes up to 40 times
usually for fly pushing and here's
something that I think is interesting we
want to talk about powerful and powerful
cavity so if you zoom in and out or with
a microscope then you want the sample to
stay in focus you don't want to readjust
the focus all the time that's pretty
boring and it's distracting and it
doesn't help you so what you do is to
you have to adjust the oculars correctly
to your dad I've seen of your eyes so
for me for example I have one died
between on the left eye and zero on the
right one so before I even sit down I
check the ocular set them up to buy
their between and then I can stop start
working and then I focus low
magnification Izu min and everything
sharp and it's relatively easy to adjust
the oka last two you need so you set the
diopter to zero you focus at a low
magnification you zoom in you adjust the
diopter and then you leave the diopter
like that and remember that position and
then it will be much more convenient
for you to work em for flies it's
important to have enough working
distance because sometimes you want to
look at the wires where the flies are
inside because you want to look at the
larva of the flies you need a large
types of field yes we will talk about
more more in detail about the depth of
field of the microscope of the new s us
which we can provide and that's because
flies are much bigger than warmth they
are much more three-dimensional and you
want to see from top to bottom and you
want to see without having to focus
through the fly on the base you need
enough space for the fly pad and you
definitely want don't want cables on the
desk because um you don't want that
something gets entangled in the cables
and it's pulling it down from the table
we offer a lot of different bases for
different applications and different
flavors and here you can see our new s 9
series on the left of the s 9e in the
middle of the s 9 d 4 documentation on
the rest the right side the s9i with the
integrated 10 megapixel camera and you
can see here some users may want a very
small base to save space some want a
medium-size base so that they can put
their hands on and some want a basis
integrated illumination also talking
about illumination we can see that you
have different options you have touring
lights you have the gooseneck and we
have some more and that's what it looks
like maybe in a typical fly lab and
that's for what I'm talking about cables
and goose necks so nothing should be in
your way because there's everything full
with wires with ethanol bottles with the
dead flies inside rubber bands etc you
have your co2 elvis's and if we would
have now additional cables for all the
illumination and light light this would
not be a good idea I think and this is
why we started at Leica to make our own
labs our own microscope lamps and I want
to give you
brief overview over what you can expect
so we have for example the ring light
that the light comes from the top and
you can switch on and off different
sequence of ring lights to improve the
contrast you can use diffusers because
ring lights often on the shiny surfaces
or flies make these patterns some users
like spotlights whose necks as they are
called better because you can make a
very nice contrast with them we can
position them freely the little
disadvantages with screws necks is when
you think the illumination is correct
and the acoustics are usually there
where you want to put your hands so we
have maybe a better solution
which we can offer you like light
illumination well there are lots of
different bases we ask which can provide
light that comes from below uniform
light if you want to check the color of
your slides directed light where you can
adjust the contrast and I have here in
the talk our new - LED basis diffuse
illumination well if you ever played
with the reflectors you have from the
ring light and this diffuser was not
enough then we have a very high diffuse
illumination highly diffuse illumination
that allows you to take shadow free
images there it's more for imaging and
less good for preparation because it
impairs a little bit of working distance
but for imaging and for documentation
that may be a very cool solution to
think about then we have the multi
contrast illumination that's one of my
favorite illuminations because it
provides the same illumination contrast
like a gooseneck but it's not always in
my hands because light comes from a
relatively flat angle from slightly
behind the microscope and I can adjust
the segments so the higher and lower and
a little bit closer together maybe and
then I get a lot more light exactly
where I need it and this is also bound
to the focus of the stereo which means
if I change the
focus position of my microscope the lamp
also moves up and down together with
microscope which i think is pretty nice
because then the lights always there
where I want and then last but not least
you have the near vertical illumination
this is where the light comes pretty
close to the object a beam path so
nearly through the objective you also
have a solution where the light goes
through the objective so for small
animal surgery for example that cool
illumination because it can deliver you
the same lighting conditions as for
example a dentist or ear nose throat
medicine physician would use em for his
patients and that's pretty cool
animation which you can use that's what
they could look in reality so we have
the spotlights the diffuse illumination
the multi contrast ring light with all
the adapters polarizer and diffuser and
here's very easy transmitted light
illumination the bli and here's another
solution where everything is integrated
and we started with this some years ago
and we found out that this is a pretty
good solution I think for those of you
labs because here you have a four point
ring light and you have this arc in the
back where you can switch on all LEDs or
just lower one and this meet allows you
to play with different scenes so life
from above light from the back at the
high angle light from the back at a very
low angle so you can see even smaller
details because they are nicely
contrasted presence which sometimes are
much better to see if they make a little
shadow and everything
zoom focuses together with your
microscope and the LEDs are arranged in
a way that they don't make too much
reflection so they are not too close not
too far away and they are always
illuminating the field of view where
you're working and we take a lot of
effort to get the colors of the LEDs
right so that you see nearly realistic
colors as good as you can achieve with
LEDs
and that you always see the reality and
make the right decision when it comes to
for example finding out different colors
in population genetics or flies so
what's important for the Flies is you
need to move space to move your thumb
around you need space for your fly pad
no borders where the fly pad hangs good
leds for good color the light should not
reflect too much it cannot completely
eliminate this but we can make a do our
best an incident like this that produces
contrast that's interesting what is that
what I just showed you the LED mm and
and here's a question about it do we
need to transmit the light for
Drosophila and I think some of you are
working with stress or Villanova and
I've already shown you the new TLC cells
in the elbow base before for C elegans
and we can also use this photo sofala
and this is where we want to play the
movie in which you can see hopefully a
Drosophila larvae which are put in a
droplet of water crawling around and you
can see nicely internal structures like
nerves
hopefully muscles etc and I played a
little bit around with the contrast to
show you what you can achieve this base
can we play the movies
[Music]
[Music]
okay I hope everyone was able to see
that we can see nicely internal
structures of that lava and maybe you
are interested and want to have a demo
of that base and we can come back to you
later when we are talking about slides
and different microscopes and
illumination techniques you also have
different microscopes which I see and
many different laboratories and there
are in principle two different kinds of
stereo microscopes both were invented in
the u.s. the one more than hundred years
ago the other not too long ago and here
we have two completely different
principles so on the right side we have
the so-called green of type on the left
side we have the so-called common main
objective and I want to explain you a
little bit more what the difference is
before I explain you when to use what or
when to consider what so on the right
side you see the green of design and
here you see I have one microscope for
every eye that's pretty good idea so you
simply take two small microscopes put
them together and then every eye has its
own microscope you put them together in
a certain angle and it like ER we look a
lot of the human physiology and we want
to look at viewing physiology so that
you get a really good 3d image and the
angle between these two microscopes is
in the queen of s 9 around 10 degrees
which corresponds most likely to the
viewing angle when you're reading a book
so if you look into the microscope it's
pretty easy to synchronize the two
images and the brain and to get a very
good very click 3d impression on the
left side we see this common main
objective design and you see there's a
big big lens the common main objective
and above we have the zoom again not to
microscope too
zooom part about this you have the tube
where the image of recreation happens
and then we have the eyepieces and the
common main objective focuses the two
beam pass onto the sample and you can
imagine if you take such a big lens and
you go through the outer part of the
lens then this is maybe not so cheap to
make but I think this is the possibility
where you can get the higher resolution
I will show you
so first advantage of the green of
design on the right side is the working
distance you have two microscopes you
have a lot of space you don't need the
big common main objective in the front
on the left side you have much less
working distance but if we look at more
detail at the CMO then you quickly
realize that okay now I have to possibly
keep to exchange objectives so on a CMO
you can have an objective revolver
because the bust of the common main
objective you have an unfinished part
you can also add illumination there or
focus with the objective only then above
we have the zoom body and above the zoom
body we have an alpha infinity space and
you can add a lot more accessories so we
think about fluorescence here you would
place your essence axis we think about
economy so here you would exchange the
tube so that you get a a go tube term we
would think about coaxial illumination
for material science yeah here you can
play a lot around and here you see the
advantage of the CMO design is the much
higher versatility and in some areas or
the regulatory because if you are
suffering from neck strain because you
always have to look in the same angle
into your queen of microscope then this
can easily easily be resolved by taking
a CMO with a virtue which can adjust to
your needs if you are working for hours
there are other advantages into the
largeness of the green off and the CMO
here on the left leg you see the green
off and you have two microscopes and
every microscope has its own focal plane
and if the two beam paths are tilted in
10 degrees then also the focus planes
are tilted and on the right side if you
go to through a common main objective
then everything is in the same focus
plane you can enlarge here the green off
stereo microscope and you see in the
middle
the yellow whether to beam pass from the
left and the right I come together
ravishing sharp but it should look for
at the left side then the left eye and
the right eye have different focus
planes and this can lead to effects like
this so the fly in the center is always
sharp and the fly at the border is on
top at least for one eye whereas with a
CMO you have a better overview so why do
many Drosophila and C elegans users use
screen of stereo microscopes and there
is a different way how they treat their
samples we see elegance you go to the
higher magnification so you put warm in
the middle in the center of the field of
view and then you zoom in so you don't
have the problem and the same is for
flies so their laboratories the Flies
are pushed with the brush and there are
laboratories where the completely fly
pet is moved around so if you always
move the fly pets over the flies in the
center you don't have a problem but if
you want large overview and to click
your variant original and male
separation at low magnification then a
CMOS may be the better solution well we
know that many users still like to see
green of better because of the
physiological viewing angle and this is
why we have invented fusion objects
what is fusion optics okay so if we look
now at CMO microscope in that case and
we have unscrewed the lens then you can
see two identical pupils or entry lenses
and here we already see a problem you
can't increase the resolution any
further because the glass is already
touching in the middle but we can make
one big and one small entry pupil for
the zoom so on the right side for the
right eye you have high resolution and
on the left side you have a lower
resolution but more depth of field and
our brain will put it easily together I
mean we have two eyes and these two eyes
never see the same thing that's why are
they are in separate places in the head
and they always put together what they
see and this can help you to improve the
depths and feel depth of field and the
resolution in one go and this is what it
looks now like on the new SD a stereo on
the right side you have large entry
pupil for very high resolution on the
left side you have a smaller mm in this
case objective for the left eye for the
larger depth of field and this means
everything looks better and focus it's
easier to distinguish and then you still
for fine adjustment put your sample in
the middle good next you want to go to
fluorescence and well let's say your
transaction was successful and your
Drosophila brains for example are
expressing some fluorescent proteins
then you need to prepare them and you
need to check them before you go to
confocal you also need to screen the
Flies and this is where we can help you
with fluorescence stereo microscopes and
that's why we have invented the triple
beam so we not only make two different
beam pass for twice
only make two different game paths of
different size who tries we simply add
assert being part for the fluorescence
and what sounds funny in the beginning
will hopefully easily be explained when
I tell you that fluorescence excitation
light does also excite for example LAN
the glue then there's glass there are
lots of different glass in zoom body
especially of a high-end stereo
microscope you expect 22 lenses or more
in the zoom body and these different
glass they can exhibit autofluorescence
and they can also be reflected from the
coating and if he goes one of the
optical beam paths for first excitation
this all will deliver a grant and
background inspect for a signal to noise
and what you want to see is maybe even
single proteins and this means you need
a very sensitive instrument which
produces no other fluorescence so we
have added a third beam pass to the
stereo microscope dedicated for
fluorescence excitation light and that
in the front of the microscope and it
zooms together with the two optical beam
pass so the light is always exciting the
entire field of view you using and if
you zooming out it gets bigger and give
you zoom in it gets smaller and brighter
another very interesting thing is that
you don't need to duck frog anymore
because the excitation light goes
through the excitation filter and the
emission light goes through the two
emission filters for both eyes and you
save a lot of light with that design if
you're looking at it from the side then
you see that in the front here on the
right side you have the excitation and
in the middle you have the two eyes
which goes to the left and the right
part of the CMO lens and the light goes
through the excitation filter comes most
likely from the metal halide lamp goes
through the optics it goes to the sample
excites the fluorescence and all the
reflexes which you have from surfaces
from plastic dishes from glass
from liquids these reflexes all go away
from the user back to the column and
this means on the inflorescence light
reaches the eye of the user or the
camera and all the reflexes stray light
and excitation order fluorescence will
never be seen by this user
now let's lock talked a little bit about
zebrafish
and the zebrafish we have again more or
less the same workflow of web steps
phenotyping picking sometimes injecting
and we always have to decide is my fish
at the right stage is the culture
culture healthy and if you're working
for example in analogy you want to know
where do I put my I set my lesion my
injection to stimulate an immune
response for example and then after you
have decided where to do what which fish
to use that you're maybe at the right
spot that you made the right injection
then you go to fluorescent screening and
after you have selected the right fish
you go to imaging here again you want to
decide what you see that what you see is
the right thing and this means you need
a pretty good transmitted light base for
this and you need a large loominator
field of view because you want to zoom
out see several fish you want a large
glass plate on top of the stage because
you will fill your petri dish around so
that the eggs go together in the center
and you should not hang somewhere and
then you want to start at a low
magnification you don't want to move
your bait receives too much anymore
because fish are swimming and if
everything shaking that's not good for
you so then you want to adjust your
contrast and then you want to adjust the
intensity and if you want to combine the
solution screening then you want it
click possibility to switch on/off the
transmitted light and that's why we've
made this new base because here is one
push of the button the light is on or
off and it remembers the last state even
if you switch the base completely off
overnight and you can even use small
foot switch that allows you to do this
with your feet so you have hands-free
operation in the back we have made a
extra hole for space for cables that we
found out if you put your transmitted
light base into a steroid cabinet or if
you have very short desks then this is
very often a problem that all the cables
come out from the back and here we have
an extra short back transmitted light
base which allows you even to be
installed on small benches or in
asteriod cabinets then talking about
contrast of a bias
why does my car make such a big new
transmitted light base well we have
found out that it is important to have
the same good contrast from the low
magnification to high magnification and
if you look at the base then it's not
sufficient to simply put the bulb under
the viewing area what you want to
illuminate and is the same on the
nominal microscope the bulb is deep
inside the foot of the microscope and
then there's optics there's a contender
and the condenser shapes and forms the
light and shines at the same numerical
aperture at the sample as the numerical
aperture of the objective otherwise you
want to reach full resolution if the
approach is too big then you get stray
light the fitting aperture is too little
then you get a very strong contrast and
another thing is if you want to do
contrasting then you have think in
normal microscopes about phase rings for
example and these phase rings are
usually in the back focal plane well the
big focal plane is
stereomicroscope is very differently
difficult because if you zoom in and out
then the big focal plane also changes so
here we have made a lot of effort to put
the contrasting element far away from
the viewing plane because as you can see
on the next slide if the contrasting
element is too close to the sample then
you can see a low magnification just
like stripe as you see here in the right
image and this usually happens just when
the context starts to get good and this
is what you see on the left side with a
new base the contrasting element is so
far away from the back focal plane so
far away from the optical focal plane
and to end up in the back focal plane so
that you get a very good and even
contrast and this is what you want
because you want this to see or fish in
the same contrast otherwise you can't
make a good decision you have to move
your fish around or whatever then in the
next slide I want to talk about contrast
this is a slide which I would never put
on our homepage because of a text
donation and you can see on the right
side well most users I asked would say
the right image looks better than the
left image but if you look in more
detail than you see on the right image
the black the black is really pitch
black and then there are white spots and
black and black there's no difference
and what we need to see is small
differences this is where the music
plays there's white and white and
there's no difference between two white
cells so I can't look deep enough inside
I maybe cannot reveal the small
structures here this means you have a
very strong contrast and this strong
contrast comes because the approach of
dead space on the right side is very low
on the left side I have an abyss there's
a much bigger picture and here you can
see all these nice details inside and
the smaller structures
and here's my proof
these are zebrafish embedded in glycerol
and on the right side and the air bubble
you see you have a very small aperture
and on the left side you see you have a
very large aperture and the large virtue
of the base allows you to see one
structures more detail and now we have a
little video of zebrafish X and I hope
you will be able to see here on the
video and the heart's pounding and the
blood flow you can really distinguish
the individual red blood cells and I if
we can replay the video now and I hope
you enjoy it
[Music]
okay I'm sorry that the video was so
short we have a longer version of this
video on our homepage just goobie 40
else 3000 arrow and I hope you can see
it good for the zebrafish imaging you
can opt for a stereomicroscope like in
that case they're like m25 FA and this
is a fully automated stereo microscope
because you maybe want to image your
fish over longer time periods and this
means you need a microscope where you
can control nearly every condition so if
you want to control remotely maybe the
zoom you want to control remotely the
shutter you want control remotely the
transmitted light that case is here the
TL 5000 elbow the their pace is highly
automated so if you change the zoom it
also changes the aperture like an
automatic condenser and you always
achieve the best contrast this base has
been optimized for high-end imaging for
high resolutions and for fully automated
tasks you maybe want to put a motor
stage or in that case a scanning stage
and top because if you have treatment
and the mock treatment you maybe want to
image both overtime is individual
positions fish are usually not staying
in one place so you maybe want to make a
jet stick from time to time and what you
need here is low excitation power and
the stereo that captures a lot of light
so it's not only about the aperture of
the microscope sometimes you need more
working distance or larger field of view
it's also about how good is the
transmission of the objectives and I
think the lighter the stereomicroscope
objectives are pretty outstanding in
that quality
sometimes you need to ex objective and
here on that one you can see a objective
revolver that can be adjusted per focal
so if you change the magnification it
also it always stays in focus and you
can continue working and we also offer
two x objective which can compensate for
up to five millimeter water column so
you can also use the correction color to
improve your image quality and we also
have a very nice video of that one on
our leg like a home page on top you want
to put a high resolution camera because
you want to get all the details and here
we can assure you you can mount nearly
every camera on a stereo we offer a lot
of different cameras with different
tasks and you can also take high end
CMOS cameras without sharing no issue to
put them on a stereo so putting it all
together the new transmitted light base
for zebrafish fits for stereos and
microscopes I didn't talk about
microscopes today but we also have some
and a transmitted light base for routine
use should work from low magnification
to high magnification and this new
transmits light base the TLC cells never
support from the 0.5 X to the 2 X and
although the 5x is a numerical aperture
of 0.5 the high in a of a base is
important but it's not the only thing
that's important you also need the
shaped light so the light needs to have
directional lights of the condenser of
the microscope modern LED base should
remain cool especially if you're working
the zebrafish you don't want to cook
them and so LED base gives you the
possibility to stay relatively cooler em
if you set the brightness of the LED
base to hundred percent it will
definitely priciple you some heat
but that's usually not necessary because
the LEDs which we use are so bright that
you can run easily at 75% and then you
will produce no heat at all but I didn't
want to redo a restricted base to lower
light intensities because then it would
be useless for other interesting tasks
like polarization etc the base should
produce no other fluorescence and we
achieved this on our high-end basis for
in two different ways on the teal 5000 I
told you that you have their perches
which adjust automatically to the
microscope and here you can close the
aperture em during fluorescence imaging
and then you can open it again for
transmitted light imaging and then you
have absolutely no background and on our
new kills 3000 ergo we have a parabolic
in the mirror inside and that deflects
the light in a way so that there's no
other presence from the LED coming back
well at least nearly no order for
essence you would need a very good
camera to show this a transmitted light
base should be easy to switch on and off
maybe even with a foot switch because
you want to combine it with fluorescence
you want to look where is my fish then
you want to check and where is my
person's protein expressed is it it
specifically are specific and you want
to decide how you go on and you need a
large illuminated field of view and this
is what all our bases can deliver and
you need LEDs is good color reproduction
because you want to see the beauty of
life in original and not something
artificial and we you need a lot of good
contrasting methods so like the light
from above which you can adjust as you
goosenecks
from the top from the left from behind
you can also adjust this like a base so
you can have the bright field the dark
field and the rotor man contrast which
is oblique illumination from below
invented by Leica some years ago when it
comes together you see there's a lot of
possibilities which you can play around
and here's my
here's what I would ask you to do when
you speak to a like a sales rep and talk
about your application and there may be
solutions you didn't expect
we have many microscopes for many
specific tasks and we always have a
possibility to help you get better
results to help you make better
decisions and help you to be head of
competition one step and our new
products they are made with you the user
in mind and with human physiology in
mind so that you see yet that you see
more that we see you as happy users and
I have shown here the new tenth
transmitted light base the TLC thousand
arrow the new fluorescent stereo M 205
FCI
the black stereo microscope and the new
screening stereo microscope ds9 which is
here my last slide good thank you very
much thank you so much dr. burgers for
that informative presentation a quick
reminder if all of you audience members
on how to submit questions simply type
them into the Q&A box found by clicking
on the green Q&A button as a lower left
of your presentation window
dr. burgers will answer as many
questions as time permits so let's begin
with our first set of questions looks
like we have quite a few coming in
here's an audience question
dr. burgers could I use this microscope
with fresh materials fresh materials
sure
well fresh materials is for me a living
specimen yes definitely or if it's
freshly excised material yes and this is
why we make the very big glass plate on
top so that you have space to put a big
box of X plate or whatever you want to
do fresh materials I think was about
transmitted light
maybe organs and something yes and even
if you spill something our base is
constructed in a way that even if
saltwater is running inside you can get
it out again I mean if you don't soak it
it will survive but you have checked our
microscopes for this and there are
spilling borders so that nothing can get
into the base into the electronics and
destroy them and the mirrors inside can
be cleaned carefully so I would say yes
I hope this answers the question I think
it does and here's our next question
the three-part question how are the
pictures erected in the green o-type are
there any distortions and how are they
corrected in the green off yes they are
there is an image erection I didn't show
the prism here my presentation and this
can be done with prisms or with mirrors
so some people some mirrors that erect
the image right before the oculus
are there any distortions well that's a
very interesting question distortion I
can think about flatness or field and
they can be constructed so that they
look plan but since you have the tilted
focus planes you will have no advantage
of this a very interesting point about
distortions color distortions and if you
go beyond 40 X then you need to
definitely plan up chromatic upper
chromatic correction otherwise you will
see color fringes and these color
fringes will be very prominent in the
green of stereomicroscope this is why
the us9 stereo microscope is a chromatic
heli corrected so that you get the best
image wonderful thank you
and I think you answered part of this
next question how are the different eye
distances collected for in the green off
type because the angle between both
beams could be changed right well if you
have the image erection prism then you
have a space where you can adjust the
inter papillary distance without
changing the viewing angle yes wonderful
thank you we have a lot of questions
coming in from our audience members
wonderful questions here's our next one
how different vision of both eyes is
corrected for not sure exactly how how
different vision of both eyes is
collected for okay and I think this is
related to fusion optics and if you have
two different optics for two different
eyes then you see definitely two
different things on both eyes and the
larger the entry pupil the more like you
are connecting collecting this means on
the right side it usually is a little
bit brighter but you won't recognize you
don't compensate for this it's not
necessary great thank you
here's our next audience question how do
you how do the green off s9 series
fusion and CMO compare for focus of the
specimens at the edge of the petri dish
is s9 closer to CMO or green off the s9
is definitely a green off the s9 allows
you to see more in focus with the left
eye which allows you to have a better
overview and a better vision and 3d
because you see also more depth but on
the right eye you have the higher
resolution and if you want to see
something really in detail then you
should position it in the center of both
beam pass there's a CMO you have no
problems in synchronous because
everything is in
same focus plane on the picture of the
petri dish on the centre thank you for
that an audience members thank you so
much for your interaction we have some
wonderful questions and we have time for
a couple of more is the light from
several LED spots homogeneous ly
scattered through the object plane yeah
I mean that's the main reason why we
started to make our own lens if we buy
lands from suppliers then they maybe
don't illuminate the focus plane
correctly if you exchange objectives
it's also meant in the past that you had
to exchange the ring light and this is
why we design our own lenses in front of
the LEDs this is why we design the
angles of the LEDs and we make sure that
from in a certain magnification range
and I means different objective range
with a different working distance range
the field of view is always correctly
illuminated so you have no dark spot in
the middle no bright tone in the middle
depending on the objective you have if
you look at one of our ring lights close
you will see that they have lenses on
top of the LEDs and these lenses have
different shape so that they really
illuminate the entire field of view
wonderful thank you
so much and we have time for one more
question our last question for now how
can one view such a video stereoscopic
way is it something like a virtual
reality uh no I took one of our cameras
I mounted it on the right beam pass I
close the aperture just a little bit
because the right beam pass is the one
with it high resolution let's get depth
of field so I increase the depth of
field a little bit and I press record at
it wonderful thank you so much dr.
burgers for a wonderful presentation
give any final comments before we end
our webinar Jay um I must say thank you
these are very inspiring interesting
questions and it shows that everyone
paid attention and I obviously hit a
spot here thank you very much if you
have more questions I think you know how
to reach us and we will be happy to
answer more questions by mail thank you
so much
to thank the audience for joining us
today for their interesting questions
I'd also like to thank our sponsors like
on micro systems for today's webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through December 1st 2017